i'm from brooklyn new york i came here
when i was three years old
from turkey and i pretty much got raised
here
and my upbringing of
well i started being a club promoter at
the age of
14 that brought me to a lot of highs
and in life where i felt like i i've
experienced
happiness and excitement in life
but uh with all good things and that it
came to a crash
where it just was not fulfilling anymore
and
that crash was very reckless and
destructive
in life we can't always keep that high
so
uh to reach to feel like we're we're
reaching for that high again
we might try different avenues so the
avenues that i've
i've tried was was drugs
and uh later which i did not even know
was could be an addiction
i've uh i i i formed a pornography
addiction which i didn't even know could
be an addiction
i just started praying five times a day
and my mother is
completely mind blown she goes this kid
this kid is always earrings you know
hair
hair spiked up smoking weed like she
knows she knew i was doing [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying and then all of
a sudden
she's like my son is praying it's like
what's going
on it doesn't make sense i just was not
was not satisfied with life and what it
had to offer to me
everybody is shocked now my brother's
shocked my my
my sister's shocked my dad was shocked i
got my whole family shocked
that you have this kid that was
completely reckless
that's praying now and and trying to
guide us i'm trying to have done praying
stuff
you know what i'm saying but when it
comes to other drugs
with weed you have red eyes with with
heroin you start
itching yourself or something like you
would try to steal and stuff like
it would be easy to spot but with
pornography you can't spawn it
yeah you would be more inclusive like
more to yourself
but people can't really spot it and now
my number one advice would be
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
it's your boys from t3m and we are
joined with a very special guest today
salaam alaikum bro how you guys doing
how you guys doing
i'm delighted we're good are you um
nice to see you guys you guys doing your
thing you know i keep up with you guys
well yeah much love much love
so tell me a little bit about where
you're from where you currently are
a little bit about your background and
upbringing
okay absolutely um i'm from brooklyn new
york i came here when i was
three years old from turkey and i pretty
much
got raised here and my upbringing
of well i started being a club promoter
at the age of
14 or 13 or 14 for team nights
and uh
that brought me to a lot of highs and in
life
where i felt like i i've experienced
the epitome of happiness and
excitement in life but uh with all good
things
it had to co it came to a crash where it
just was not fulfilling anymore
and that crash was very reckless
and destructive so
just because you can't in life we can't
always keep that high
so uh to reach to feel like we're
we're reaching for that high again we
might try different avenues
so the avenues that i've i've tried was
was drugs and uh
later which i did not even know was
could be an addiction
i've uh i i i formed a pornography
addiction which i didn't even know could
be an addiction
yeah it's one of the worst ones man yeah
because it's so available it's free it's
there and
it's not just the explicit stuff
on these websites it's on instagram it's
on facebook
it's on youtube it's on the billboard
across the street
yeah absolutely and sometimes like even
my friends
uh like i see them following these
instagrammers on
on um these instagrams on instagram
instagram models whatever and it's just
it's just funny to me so i'm like
what's your intention like
yeah like you what do you what what do
you think's going to happen
yeah you know literally
yeah they're liking every picture too
like what is that gonna do bro
like she's not gonna have an aha moment
and be like oh
he's the one you know this guy right
here
out of all the guys that are liking my
pictures
this guy right here that's got 200
followers he's
i'm gonna give it up to him don't the
way his eyes are
no profile i know man
and then what happened after that bro so
what happened after that
so um so having that that very
destructive um thing whatever
uh one summer usually i would use to
turkey every other summer or every
summer sometimes
and one summer i go to turkey and i'm on
my
my aunt's house and mind you
like i don't know anything about islam i
don't know anything about like i don't
even like the little kids in the
neighborhood were making fun of me
they were asking me the pr what's the
prophet's name and i i didn't know you
know
they were just laughing at me pointing
at me you know what i'm saying
so one day i'm just sitting at sitting
at home and i'm literally
there's there's like a hundred channels
and wallahi there's not
one thing interesting on tv if there was
one thing interesting on tv
when the event went off i would not have
went to the mustang today
if there was one thing interesting i was
searching
very like i was really searching for
something interesting on tv whatever
the advantage goes off and my aunt is
like oh you and your cousin should go to
the mosque
my cousin doesn't pray whatever so he
said you guys should go to the mosque
and while she's talking i'm still trying
to flick through the channels and
still nothing so i'm like yeah whatever
let me go to the mosque
so we go to the mosque and my cousin's
like briefly telling me oh
we do we do before we pray and whatnot
so whatever we do we do and we i go
upstairs to pray
and as soon as the door opened and i
walk inside the
the like the prayer area where the rug
is whatever
i just had like a crazy like epiphany
where
uh you know like those old film strips
that you could just pull out
and it was this bunch of squares like
bunch of cutouts
literally i saw that with every mistake
i made in my life it just
flipped through my head mad quickly even
though it went through fast
i've seen like every snippet
and i just started crying
i just started crying and i i didn't
understand it
but um so i i was praying that dana and
i really got
like i really got touched so whatever
let me make it uh short so
in my journey there i just started
praying five times a day
and my mother is completely mind blown
she goes this kid
this kid is always earrings you know
hair
hair spiked up looking like some like a
like a club promoter
smoking weed like she knows she knew i
was doing [ __ ] you know what i'm saying
and then all of a sudden she's like my
son is praying
he's like what's going on it doesn't
make sense you know so
i sustained that whole time there i was
like you know what
i don't know if this is the truth but my
experience i definitely
felt it that's number one and number two
is
i don't i said i knew i had to hold on
to something
because or else i was i felt like i was
gonna die or something because
i just was not was not satisfied with
life and what it had to offer to me
and um so yeah i just completely changed
changed my life there so mind you like
my um so we go back
come back to brooklyn whatever and then
like everybody's shocked now my
brother's shocked my
my sister's shocked my dad is shocked i
get my whole family shocked
that you have this kid that was
completely reckless
that's praying now and trying to guide
us i'm trying to have no praying stuff
you know what i'm saying so it was funny
but um
what ended up so before that i was
watching pornography and there but i
just didn't feel the need to
but this this is this is um this is when
did that
experience happen at the masjid how old
we i was
right before my 18th birthday and how do
you know
i'm turning 30 in august
yes so um uh
what was i gonna say oh yeah so be
before i
i used to watch uh pornography here and
there but i just never felt the need to
oh and um
so when i started become religious quote
unquote
i had to cut off a lot of people because
i
i was just scared to fall down that path
again but
in the meantime i'm i'm still
researching on my religion i'm still
praying
you know what i'm saying i'm still
trying to be the best muslim i could be
so i'm still researching
and i'm learning at a rapid rate but um
i didn't realize that yeah i was able to
leave
other addictions but
pornography caught back up with me
because
i cut off everybody and i was just home
i was just constantly home so
and and mind you at 18 years old this is
like the peak of your
of um like your sexual drive
so constantly being home and um
i just started growing the habit again
of watching pornography
and what what happened was um
i just uh what was i going to say
i just lost my train of thought
yeah when you start okay go ahead i was
just gonna
ask something as intermission yes so um
it came back and it was and i've i
realized it was addiction because
like i was begging to i was begging in
the prayers
so i had to leave it like i don't i
don't want it no more because oh
an important ass important note i've
realized i had an addiction
when i was praying my all my salas in
the last
seconds so let's say if assad is at 4 30
and and i would pray at like 4
20 no yeah at 4 20 of us it was at 4 30.
like literally the other salas were like
i would pray
right before the 10 minutes before the
other selez
but i never understood like how can i
leave this how can i leave this i tried
so much
and then like a little bit of research
and
and going to uh like a therapist or
something
to learn about it and it hit me
it hit me because um
it hit me because even even when i in
like the very
like the very um high high times of
being religious
i didn't address a certain things in my
life and this this this is gonna how
it's all gonna spiral back
so my brother and my father was always
working so my mother and my sister
always raised me
so unconsciously i grew i got a lot of
their
traits and a man should never a man
should never
learn learn how to be
himself from a woman you know what i'm
saying
but if that's the only if that's the
only thing you have
that's the only thing you have you know
what i'm saying
so i had i've realized that
that i was not addressing problems in my
life and i was scared of tension
that was my main problem i was
constantly avoiding tension
between what just being in tense
situations
that's what happens that's what happens
though
so i was just constantly pushing away
any kind of tension
when it came to like i wouldn't mind
being stepped on
as long as there was no tension wow
yeah it was it was bad but um
but uh learning about myself and
being real with myself and understanding
my emotions
and um and who are who i am
and about the red about red pill and
whatnot
about addressing your problems going
into tension and speaking
speaking them out letting things out
it really changed my life it changed my
life a lot
because it was it was it was no longer
hidden
so things that bothered me in the past i
addressed every single problem i went up
to these people
i called these people i suppose i like
even talked to my pops i was like my i
was like pops when you did someone sold
thing
when i was 11 years old that that [ __ ]
my life up
you know what i'm saying that that ruins
things for me that
that if you would have never did that
because i felt helpless
when i saw something when i was when i
heard when i saw something
and i and it really bothered me for many
years and i didn't know how to address
it
you know what i'm saying but then when i
spoke to him face to face like a man
he was denying it he still denied it but
the fact that it was not for him it was
it was for myself
i told him i told him how i felt i was
like what you did
i was like that was terrible and you
ruined my life
yeah so let letting loose
it helped me to it it broke the shackles
of addiction
pretty much masha'allah and in the
process you found yourself in
in a tense situation in a state of
conflict and you went for it
because you knew you had to now i don't
shy away
i don't shy away words don't hurt me no
more people get tight now
people get so tight when they say things
and it doesn't affect me
and i just i save something back to them
and they get tight
i just laugh now um
[Music]
i'm like i made such a big drastic
change in my life i'm so grateful
where i am in my life but it's not it's
not to just say it for myself
this is disabled i know there's kids
watching too where
because the way pornography is such a
sneaky addiction
like you could have an addiction nobody
would know
but when it comes to other drugs with
weed you will have red eyes
with with heroin you start itching
yourself or something
like you would try to steal and stuff
like it would be easy to spot
but with pornography you can't spawn it
yeah you would be more inclusive
like more to yourself but people can't
really spot it and now my number one
advice would be
to tell somebody you trust to to speak
it out
because you can it's it's it can't be
just you and shaytan
you know what i'm saying you can't just
grapple with shaytan all day
every day it's just a losing battle yeah
that's fine i remember i did the
same exact thing you just said actually
in two occasions like bro
your story is aligning so much with my
story
in certain ways obviously you know your
story is unique to yours
but um you telling your pups about the
thing that happened that affected you
bro like i got abused as a kid from my
stepdad
and like later on in life like 22 23
i had realized what you realized i was
like yo i can't run away from this i
need to like
i need to deal with this i need to
confront it and i literally
hit him up met him in person i hadn't
seen him in like
four years and basically told him
everything i was like yo
like everything you did when i was
little i just want to let you know
that that really did mess me up like it
made me suicidal made me
go through all this turmoil but i want
to let you know that i forgive you
not because i want you back in my life
but because it's just not something that
i want to hold on to and bro he did
exactly what your dad did bro
he denied everything he played the
victim card
and it's like dude i'm forgiving you bro
like it's you're forgiven you do not
have to
deny you don't have to play the victim
card just accept it but
man say some people they're too caught
up here
in the ego bro they have this story of
how it is
who they are and what plays out bro what
100 percent
100 like especially in the turkish
community
like the reality is not so important the
more important thing
is how people view them and how
yep dr steph curious was telling us an
episode that a lot of
um people not just turks he was saying
turks but i see this in a lot of middle
eastern and some south asian communities
too
being their ethnicity so like being turk
for example is more important than being
a muslim
100 100
and it's it's it's sad because i feel
like they have to
to sustain something but they don't
realize that
you don't realize that everybody sees
through it
like the people the people that that
really try i got family members like
that
that try to keep it perfect and like
they would tell me that their son has
straight a's
and i would speak to their their son's
friend and they'll tell me oh
your your cousin's special ed i was like
oh
come to find out my cousin a special ed
their parents would tell me straight a
uh honorable student
yeah that's messed up oh so
question for you when you
were going through the whole pornography
thing who did you tell
and what was your experience with that
so who i knew i wanted to tell people
that i was not gonna really know or see
oh i did tell one of my friends i did
tell one of my friends
but they didn't really stay like oh we
all have everybody's addicted to porn
it's nothing
like they're like oh yeah you're
addicted i'm addicted too like
i'm like nah bro
i'm not we're not addicted to the same
it's not it's ruining my life
like it's one of my life where i'm
making dua i'm like yo allah take my
take my life
you know i'm saying like i don't want to
do this no more like this is too much
you know what i'm saying but um
but yeah i'm just understanding your
emotions speaking your emotions
and another thing that really helped me
it's common like to the kids just calm
the hell down
like calm down you don't gotta like
you don't gotta like um you don't have
to be all like
like all like crazy triggered you know
what i'm saying that's why it's so
important for these kids to not be on
their phones too much
because they have low attention span and
they're like always like triggered and
stuff
it's it's it's never good to be
too high when you're happy or too set
too down when you're sad
the middle thing it when you're in the
middle
you always know the right words to say
in any confrontation
you always know the right right things
to say in any situation
because when you're calm you can think
clearly and then you won't
you won't go back walking back and be
like oh
um i should have said this man i should
have said this
that's that's going to exit out the
equation because when you're calm
you could speak directly and it just
comes out it just flows
yeah that's not supportive but you
so you only told friends you never told
like a family member or anything like
that where you were going oh no
they wouldn't understand no they
wouldn't understand exactly
they wouldn't understand like they'll
just tell me oh uh just
just stop you know just stop it
listen let me let me share something
with you with all y'all cause i never
told the ceo
when i had found out that i had a porn
addiction
first person that i told was my mom
because i knew i had to tell someone i
was like i gotta get this out
i need help because i was having trouble
it was
bro i did not know how to suck so i told
my mom
you know what my mom said you should go
to a psychologist
i was like damn like what what a good
mother and then i
after that i was like you know what i i
need to tell someone else because that
didn't
do it for me so you know what i told
next
i told my girlfriend at the time bro i
pulled up to her house
and i remember like i was crying in the
car like telling her
you know what she told me that's your
problem
you got to take care of it pro
like i was so hurt by that and then i
told my dad
and then my dad basically i don't know
my dad didn't really know how to handle
it
then he told his dad my grandpa then
told his wife and bro like
it it just made me ashamed bro you know
what's a saddest thing
the saddest thing is people people don't
even know about it
people aren't even aware and if you look
at the statistics
it's it's most of the muslim countries
that's that's watching porn
fox because you have to look at this
these people
they're innocent they they want to stay
away from xena they don't want to go
have premarital sex so they have a lot
of alone time and they have this
this crazy sex drive that they need that
they need to unleash
instead of instead of channeling it and
maybe going to mma or boxing or
something
they're just working maybe they might
even have time for that
because in these countries they barely
make anything
you know so just uh
they have so much time so they have all
the sex that sex will drive that they
don't know what to do with it
so pornography is just uh here it's
free and people are not sorry
consequences you know
but man like i'm saying this because
like yes it's important to tell someone
but the person who you tell or more so
who you tell is the most important thing
what i mean by that is like
what really started the whole journey
for me bro is like
i didn't even know about god i was
atheist at the time
i was eighties bro well he was eighties
and i remember sitting down
learning about meditation and i remember
and my first time that i meditated
i felt something not what you felt in
the mosque
but i felt something and i was like
it's not real atheism is not real like
there's something else and just that
little experience is what began to
free me from everything that i had and
wrote that right there
it wasn't me going to a person with me
going to the creator
and i didn't even know i was going to
the creator bro that's crazy
and two things i want to add pornography
makes men feminine
oh yes 100
like more like like shy and reserved
and like you don't feel like you're
worthy to speak sometimes
like you're not like your words don't
have any meaning so you can't say it
with confidence
and uh what was i going to say
oh i did go to those meetings they have
essay meetings and a meetings and all
these other meetings for uh
to recover from pornography but the the
one thing that
really really helped me is when i
started making the connection
between the red pill and
the sahaba's life's life on the side
because before before the actions of
sahabahs didn't make sense to me
sometimes
and would be real with y'all i'm like yo
why they act in a certain way why they a
certain way
you know and then looking into red pill
not the extreme version of it
how it it might like a lot of people
like you don't got to be all rowdy and
[ __ ] like that's like they're not black
people mgtow not that
you know what i'm saying like that's
just butt hurt men
but understanding red bull red red pill
that's when it really opened my mind
that's what my
journey really started i'm like
oh that's why these certain men i've met
in my life
we're behaving a certain way i'm like
these men some of these men where i
thought that their responses to certain
situations
is oh they're terrible people for
talking like that
but they were actually being honest and
truthful
because uh like i said pornography makes
you feminine
so i felt like like them being truthful
and honest like other men being truthful
honest
was them being mean i i
i didn't understand it it didn't make
sense to me you know what i'm saying
but understanding the uh red pill and
understanding
how how the the sahaba were
looking at things for what it is like
even in islam
when you're praying we're not praying
for the feeling we're praying
no you're immunized we're praying to
we're going to pray not the feeling
because then you're worshiping the
feeling
like things are just like to accept
things for what it is
number one thing like i said before is
speaking you got to speak it out it just
has to come out already
like this there might be some people
that that's still holding in
we'll just let it out bro and if people
are making fun of you you're not your
true friends
fact satisfaction that's why the first
step is always admitting you have a
problem
when it comes to dealing with addiction
so uh it's kind of la that's facts man
yeah honestly that's a very touching
story man like i was preaching this
whole time just listening i'm like damn
it's kind of luck
it's so relatable too yeah and but but
like you living it firsthand
me living it firsthand angel romney
living in first firsthand yeah we had
the start in our mind we're the only
ones
but it's like if we don't talk about
enough nobody else will know that
it's not just you bro it's not just you
g it's everyone we all had the same
thing growing up or something similar
different shape right but unless we talk
about it we're never going to improve as
a collective
yeah that's that's so true i remember i
met this one muslim brother
in a in a msa and
like he was always praying and one day
we had
he just he was so pissed off i was like
yo bro what's wrong bro
he goes yo i can't freaking leave it i
can't leave it
i'm like what are you talking about he
goes yo pornography is destroying me
like
you just like and i was scared to tell
him i was struggling with it too
but he was just like so pissed off like
he was just bursting
he was like yo i can't i can't pray or
anything
he's like my mom's always annoying me to
pray because
you can't have your heart can't have
pornography and salah
and islam at the same time
it just can't i tried i tried it myself
it was it's just it's it's so hard to
sustain
because like i said you're making these
celeste when there's only like five ten
minutes left
there was times i made salads when
there's two minutes left right before
the next salad
where i'm trying to rush i'm like oh
[ __ ] i got like five minutes let me go
make gustle
and it's so crazy and it's so ridiculous
and it's so sad that it's not just us
it's so many people struggling with this
yeah yeah you can't hold hands with
shaytan and
allah at the same time yeah what were
some of the i know we got just under
like five minutes left but we can wrap
it up what were some of your main
and i don't mind doing this again
because we definitely need a part two
but what were your main takeaways bro
of uh your journey what really helped
you leave leave porn
definitely definitely red pill was
number one and number two
number number two is understanding
myself and my emotions so
oh a book that i highly highly highly
recommend
is emotional intelligence by daniel
goldman i read that book i fell in love
with it
i understood myself so much like
it just i hope make sense of my life
experience
and it was crucial so
definitely understanding red pill uh i'm
just trying to
trying to understand your own emotions
and also at the same time
realize that your emotions and what you
want to speak or what not
it might not equal what's going on in
society right now
it might not make with your emotions and
your thinking with how society is run
right now
it's it's it's a it's a feminist society
and
men are like little boys are taught that
oh
uh like women are better women are
smarter women are it's
it's [ __ ] we're different
you know what i'm saying well we're the
same exactly we're different bro
y'all remember as uh the sight of allah
but we're different when it comes to
we're just different biological sex
differences hundred percent bro
and they can't accept the fact that men
are stronger than women there's nothing
i can tell you
i can we can't continue the subject we
can't continue talking
if you can't accept that men are
generally stronger than
women physically if you can't accept
this then basic stuff yeah
yeah but it's funny because you have
some dudes
who they uh they do trans they do the
surgery to become a woman
and then they compete in sports as a
trans woman
smash these records
i sort of i sort of i saw some of
those fights bro yo the i felt so bad
for the girls
bro yeah i felt so bad their whole face
she had like one of the one shorty had
like a whole balloon on her forehead
oh i know you're talking about that i
think something
just very vic or something like that i
don't know bro i just saw a quick
picture i was like yeah i'm good yeah
she fought the asian chick
yeah that was wild bro but uh you guys
have things to do like
like i know uh brother fayette was
telling me about how he has somebody
right after you're gonna do that
that's cool you know i'm sad i won't
take up your time mm-hmm
no well the last thing is definitely
part two last thing i want to throw in
here because what you said
about like we're in a feminine society
as men we've been conditioned even from
like a very young age i'll remember as
kids
that little thing that um the girls used
to sing
the yeah i think i know what you're
talking about
guys go to jupiter to get more stupider
girls go to college to get more
knowledge yeah yeah
i was well as a little kid i was like
what
even as a kid i was like i never sat
right with me i was like what yeah
yeah or like first the worst
second the best oh my god how does that
literally make sense bro that's oxy
moronico
yeah third is the one with the hairy
chest that's crazy no we have third the
nerve
yeah anyways bro part two for sure
because it was real like you know what
i'm saying like
it's like an angle like yo bro
before bro you were uh you were watching
my
youtube channel yeah when i found out
you were muslim bro i was like yo
that's lit
yeah no guys write down below hashtag
freedom from addictions if you want a
whole episode not even a part two we'll
do a whole episode with you
with that being said is that book you
recommended
is that the one that like explains
everything from an islamic perspective
no i think i've heard about it it's not
it's it's
it's by uh it's some new york or some
jewish old man
daniel goldman emotional intelligence
read it definitely so yeah
with you guys you know i like you you
know
great uh the book you're talking about
on hell was by sheikh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]